soy el branding y ayuda a desarrollar el
programa camp de matemáticas aquí en el
club de chicos y chicas del condado chef
y
algo importante de lo que hacemos es la
asesoría uno-a-uno con los chicos
tenemos un grupo de magníficos
voluntarios de la comunidad
muchos de ellos han enseñado antes
algunos hasta en universidad y todos
tienen un gran entusiasmo para trabajar
con los chicos
el software de cannes se está usando
internacionalmente es verdaderamente
extraordinario incluye vídeos cortos de
10 minutos o menos y problemas les da a
los chicos información sobre cómo van a
los asesores también les ayudan también
tiene una serie de magníficos incentivos
los chicos ganan puntos de energía y les
encanta ganar estos puntos de energía
cuando ya tienen estos puntos de energía
aquí los pueden usar para comprar en lo
que llamamos la tienda cam que tiene
pequeños obsequios a veces alimentos
tratamos de que sean alimentos
saludables y así los chicos pueden
convertir lo que han aprendido en
matemáticas los puntos que han ganado en
algo tangible y parece que a los chicos
les encanta kahn le ha ayudado
definitivamente a mejorar en matemáticas
ella era una alumna promedio y ahora
está en un nivel avanzado y creo que can
ha sido una gran ayuda y los maestros
también ella se esfuerza mucho para
ganar esos puntos y poder gastarlos y
para mejorar sus habilidades en
matemáticas
los chicos vienen una vez a la semana
durante más o menos hora y media y
ocupan la mitad de ese tiempo en la
computadora haciendo ejercicios con el
software de khan academy pero no se
tratan además de sentarse en la
computadora creemos que es muy
importante especialmente para ellos en
esta edad en secundaria hacer algo
activo así que combinamos el trabajo en
la computadora y algo de trabajo en el
pizarrón con juegos que requieren de
actividad física uno de los juegos que
los chicos disfrutan más es mate balón
pateado juegan una especie de béisbol
pero cuando llegan a una base tienen que
responder una pregunta de matemáticas si
no aciertan quedan fuera a menos que el
jardinero quien atrapa el balón también
falla en responder la pregunta en este
caso ambos tienen otra oportunidad a los
chicos les gustan mucho están corriendo
dejando salir algo de la energía
acumulada cuando están en la computadora
se divierten y lo más importante
aprenden matemáticas así que pensamos
que es una parte importante del programa
creemos que estamos haciendo una gran
labor con los chicos y los padres
también
a medida queremos hacer más ahora
estamos limitados por el tamaño de
nuestro laboratorio de computación
tenemos 12 computadoras y algunas de
ellas a veces fallan nos encantaría
poder ayudar a más chicos tanto aquí en
celaya como en nuestro otro club en
buenavista en donde no tenemos ninguna
computadora quisiéramos encontrar la
manera de hacer llegar el programa a más
chicos pero para ello necesitamos más
recursos